[Musique]
la série se poursuit pour Montini le
brotonneux quatre défaites consécutives
les handballeuses inontaine se sont
incliné à domicile 21 à 19 contre Harne
l'équipe avant dernière au classement de
la Nationale 2 à deux places du club
cinquantinois je pense qu'on s'est dit
qu'elles étaaiit dans les dernières donc
on allait gagner je pense que
psychologiquement on s'est pas mise
dedans et donc sur le match on était non
chalante on était lente on pourit pas
assez on c'était vite fatigué et du coup
perte de balle sur perte de balle pas
d'efficacité au tir donc on a eu
beaucoup de de tir manqués c'est une
éipe qui plus faible voilà on mène
quasiment tout le match et on se fait
dépasser sur quelques minutes
malheureusement les minutes essenti
l'excès de confiance contraste avec les
derniers résultats Montini le Bretonneux
n'a plus gagn depuis le 18 novembre 2023
résultat les inon pointent à la 9e place
j'espère redresser la barre assez
rapidement cette début d'année là pour
essayer de un se maintenir et de pouvoir
faire une aller belle potentiellement
avec une montée l'année prochaine et ça
commencera lors de la 15e journée
Montini le Bretonneux se déplacera à
Tessi le 10 février un adversaire direct
au classement une victoire permettrait
aux cquantinoises de se
relancer